c'est immanquablement c'est la vente aux
conditions habituelles de 16% plus des
enchères paiement strictement content
après chaque lot une continuation cet
après midi à partir de 14 heures jusqu'à
18h tout d'abord j'appelle pour les
dossiers judiciaires monsieur madame
redman ou quelqu'un pour les représenter
monsieur madame rain man ou quelqu'un
pour les représenter sur mana mauvaise
man nous prononçons le défaut les objets
qui ont été saisis a mené seront vendus
ça joue alors premier lot s'il vous
plaît nous mettons en vend un peu qu'on
regarde il oscars avec son mac là allez
commençons à 300 francs ressent projet
world le preneur à 320 300 voix sur 320
50 kg 1 304 centre des attentions
pressantes on le convertit annonce 1 406
en belgique pas de regrets nous oui
environ 400 406 derrière 124-110 accents
10420 quatre enfants oui des pechos oui
quatre ans on renonce à 403 cran sur
deux qu'un tranchant et jacques a330
fois il nous
ironise monsieur giraud niveau c'est pas
le ch non c'est non je crois pas mais
s'est heurtée par la réserve accueille
8 rue des abattoirs gazinière rue balore
alors sans fouille à preneur par
monsieur l'or noir 100 x 100 x 110 110
120 120 5 à
170 franchir la côte et le mois
s'agissant trouvera pas nonchalant 70
en france 170 francs des prix dérisoires
pour des objets achetés au prix fort et
qui échoue ainsi à la salle des ventes
aujourd'hui de plus en plus les familles
ne peuvent plus payer ce qu'elles
doivent
[Applaudissements]
notre enquête a commencé près d'orléans
dans une cité d'urgence
[Musique]
monsieur legrand comment faites vous
pour vous en sortir avec
1400 francs par mois ben ça c'est dur
je pense bien de tous les jours
enfin on arrive à se débrouiller quand
même
vous faites un autre travail oui bon je
fais un petit travail en noir enfin ce
qui est interdit par la loi
vous voyez combien d'heures par jour
commençait à quelle heure je commence
enfin ma journée réelle commence à 6
heures le soin jusqu'à 2h30 du matin je
veux commence dès 8h30 hne de 8 heures
le matin jusqu'à 5 heures le soir
je fais un gros travail oui enfin quand
on veut gagner son casse croûte je veux
pas d'autre moyen pour
paris va s'en sortir
vous avez été exclus des hlm parce que
vous ne pouviez plus payer votre loyer
vous êtes actuellement dans une cité
d'urgence vous vivez avec quatre enfants
dans deux pièces des pièces mais vous
payez encore le loyers des hlm oui je
paye encore depuis combien de temps ça
fait quatre ans que je paye
21 mille francs vous devez encore
combien fois que ça tout est dans la
somme de 4000 francs
vous avez réussi à acheter une
télévision oui
pas pour moi parce que j'ai pas le temps
de la regarder mais pour les enfants qui
me la rive la mène depuis car maintenant
tous les gosses ont la télé chez eux
alors y avec les miens qu'on n'avait pas
la peur de la saisie
non monsieur je crois rien parce que tu
crois pas qu'on vienne me saisir d'abord
je laisserai pas emmener ma télévision
par n'importe quel moyen c'est à dire
parce que lui si
il aurait fort à faire avant de prendre
ma télévision
[Musique]
pourquoi parce que j'estime que j'ai du
mal à gagner que kim fasse qui me
retiennent davantage que le salaire mais
qui laisse la télé aux enfants c'est
leur seul loisir du jeudi du mercredi
et après l'école mme
[Musique]
que deux oui enfin c'est une question
d'habitude maintenant
[Musique]
vous payez tout ce que vous devez
comment
j'ai une saisie arrêt sur salaire et
j'ai espoir de l'argent percepteur pour
des amendes que j'ai eu sur la voie
publique ou à défaut d'assurance des
bêtises que j'ai commis
l'entretien 21 1000e presque 22 23 mills
a dépendu du mois que je gagne on
retient depuis quatre ans je suis dans
la maison
[Musique]
est vide donne à peu près environ 200
francs au percepteur tous les fans mois
comment allez-vous vous en sortir leur
payant petit à petit
au travail on
s'est peut-être une chance on sait
jamais
j'ai au tiercé tous les dimanches
s'essayer à dire c'est ça me coûte 3
francs mais la chance n'est pas avec moi
j'ai jamais gagné il suffit d'une fois
enfin c'est qu'une question de temps
maintenant
1400 francs par mois
+ 700 francs soit 2100 francs pour 18
heures de travail par jour
[Musique]
les smicards comme monsieur le gant et
ceux qui touchent un salaire inférieur
au smig représente environ 11 % de la
population active ce sont eux d'abord
qu'ils ont affaire à la justice
orléans le dossier des impayés
s'accumulent sur le bureau du président
du tribunal monsieur le juge vous avez
eu ce matin dans votre bureau des
mauvais payeurs qui n'arrivent plus à
payer oui comment est-ce que ça se passe
et bien j'en ai eu un certain nombre ce
matin comme toutes les semaines il
s'agit de personnes qui ont des têtes a
diverti d'ailleurs c'est peut-être des
loyers ça peut être des échéances de
crédit des primes d'assurance ou espèce
de chose en général des sommes
relativement peu importante et les
créanciers qui n'ont pas trouvé de bien
à saisir estime que le salaire par la
continuité et la sécurité qu'il
représente dans la vie du salarié est
peut-être le gage le plus sûr
avant de que le salaire ne puisse être
saisie il faut que les partis viennent s
explique et je m'aperçois à ce moment là
que ses débiteurs sont le plus souvent
des gens de condition modeste
et devant un juge ou il se présente seul
un juge qui est en robe noire par
définition en présence de l'adversaire
qui est représenté par un avocat qui a
un dossier
eh bien ils n'ont rien à dire et la
seule chose qu'ils peuvent dire j'ai
trois enfants je ne gagne que 1400
francs par mois et je ne peux pas payer
alors dans ce cas là le juge n'a pas
beaucoup de moyens pour empêcher la
saisie arrêt du salaire surtout s'il y a
déjà une décision de justice qui les a
condamnés
boigny sur bionne à dix kilomètres
d'orléans
l'histoire de ce petit village c'est
celle d'un mot traditionnels qui est
passé en cinq ans de 400 à plus de 2000
habitants par la création d'un
lotissement qui a permis à des familles
de condition modeste d'accéder comme on
dit à la propriété
on trouve ici rassemblés tout ce qui
peut donner l'illusion de la prospérité
et du confort
c'est là que vivent monsieur madame
porto avec leurs six enfants ancien
peintre en bâtiment monsieur porto
travaille aujourd'hui dans une
entreprise de papier peint
[Musique]
les difficultés financières énormes ont
amené la famille a réclamé elle-même la
mise sous tutelle de leur budget
c'est-à-dire concrètement à laisser
gérer les allocations familiales par le
service des tutelles d'orléans afin de
payer les créanciers
quand une voiture qui vient dans le coin
je regarde si c'est chez nous qu'il
s'arrête
je vis toujours avec la hantise de voir
une voiture s'arrêter chez moi depuis
j'ai eu la saisie de la maison j'ai
quand y'a une voiture qui s'arrête j'ai
toujours peur que ça soit un huissier
qui s'amène tu sais pas pourquoi c'est
toujours ça un bruit de voiture je
regarde toujours
[Musique]
j'ai pu m'en sortir parce que j'ai une
assistante sociale qui m'avait donné
conseille de faire une demande du
week-end avec mon mari aussi mis
d'accord on l'a fait c'est ce qui nous a
sauvés autrement seraient je sais pas où
tu es tu en as chelem chose qu'on avait
horreur parce qu on en sortait et qu'on
avait eu une vie impossible pendant six
ans parce qu'elle avait des enfants qui
pleuraient toutes les bulles alors
c'était charmant parce que j'en aurai
fini par avoir des prises de bec avec
les voisins et c'est pas toujours la
meilleure solution
six enfants
vous êtes 2
comment se présente votre situation
budgétaire tout l'est moins et à partir
de quel moment ça devient
pratique elle est investie critique il
arriverait alors expliquez moi combien
rentrer qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
qu'est ce que c'est votre budget il
vient il rate à peu près trois cent
soixante mille contente salaire de mon
mari puis les allocations il faut
compter à peu près 180 francs 1800
francs pour le mettant le loyer les
crédits
manaudou s'était enfin je compte la
moitié pour payer ce que j'ai à payer et
le reste c'est pour manger pour manger
faux excessivement d'argent et on fait
pas d'abus je mets les enfants à la
cantine en semaine comme ça si je suis
tout seul moi vous savez est aussi placé
va très bien et mon mari comme il va
travailler pour un autre emploi chez moi
s'il va rentrer manger enfin il va
falloir qu'on sait qu'on se restreignent
sommes activement au maximum sans priver
les enfants
parce que les enfants ils ont toujours
besoin de quelque chose ce qu'il y a sur
la nourriture je trouve que c'est de
plus en plus chez
un jour là vient énormément la viande
les légumes parce que quand
on dit que vous avez une étude pour
moins de 200 francs des fois ça fait ça
fait cher bon bah ce que je fais
j'achète de la salade moi je marche pas
tellement personnellement j'en achète
pour mon mari hommage m'arrange pour la
salade phase le soir au lieu de mettre
tout le midi
autrement dans les pommes de terre on
les achète par grosses quantités au
début de l'hiver
tant qu'on a des pommes de terre on est
sauvés nous ce que les enfants c'est
encore ce qu'il mange le mieux avec les
potes le riz et puis pour la viande est
là bien des chefs a depuis depuis le
mois de septembre
à banias supermarché et je regarde à la
viande a réclamé alors finalement comme
aux jo forte parle par le travail au
noir
moi il me fasse si on aurait pu épargner
serait présenté et puis
c'est ce qui nous a permis de mettre les
enfants en colonie de vacances
autrement
cette année on prenait pas de vacances
et puis on sent qu'on est marié je peux
dire j'ai eu trois semaines de
tranquillité les enfants est en colonie
salle aura fait même le plus grand bien
et très enchantés de leur séjour
dans les colonies c'était la première
fois qu'ils partaient donc j'ai dit oui
j'ai travaillé au noir ça a payé vos
premières vacances travail au noir ça ça
nous a permis de partir dix jours 1 du
jour dans de la famille dans les
pyrénées
et ça fait du bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vais me débarrasser de vie non
la fin du mois de janvier ce sera
particulièrement plus difficile mois de
janvier je sais pas comment il va se
passer parce que
j'ai pas mal de grosses notes que
j'attends et puis comme on m'avait les
arrêter lionel aussi vous pensez à vos
enfants mais maintenant je dois leur
faire quand même faut pas le suivre et
non plus on voit un noël c'est 8 fait
des enfants je leur fais une moyenne de
30 francs par enfant
et puis c'est tout
quelque chose complète avec un disque ou
un jeu de contre un jeu de construction
des trucs comme ça mais dans les jeux
éducatifs
c'est terriblement cher aussi mes
questions
golts on est tous à nos rien n'est pas
on peut pas
c'est pas la peine de faire
du chichi puis pas manger du tout une
dernier jour du mois qui nous restera
parfois de ce principe là il vaut mieux
rien faire et puis puis vit normalement
mois complet
je crois que
j'ai dit ce que je pouvais ce que je
pouvais dire
[Musique]
cette voiture elle représente beaucoup
de sacrifices financiers ouais
surtout ça
le samedi pour
dimensionner les gamins faire du sport
tout ça soit on reste enfermé
[Musique]
la voiture coûtera 900 francs par mois
pendant deux ans
la maison 840 francs par mois pendant 20
ans
[Musique]
financièrement vous allez pouvoir y
arriver ben vous dit en faisant un
travail noah et la voiture à faire
[Musique]
à part ton travail noir dans la région
chez les gens que vous connaissez ouais
surtout dans le petit village comme
savent tout le monde enfin tout le monde
en fait tout le monde fait par semaine
par la camaraderie baisse pour ça les
gens pourraient pas s'en sortir non et
tout le monde fait ça
[Musique]
je promets le camarade dans mon métier
là pour un cap rouge et noir elle va
travailler tous les français font ça
ouais ouais en tant que fichier vous
vous sentez la
présidence cr7 de fin de mois ça prend
beaucoup avec des pièces de cinq francs
de plus par an et 2 55e
[Musique]
les gens viennent
toujours chez vous
j'habite lui il a toujours la même
clientèle les habiter quelques
amendements de départ 3 difficile où la
marque ajouté 18 mois vous avez tué on
ne peut pas laisser des gens sans manger
et clients fidèles quand ça se fait que
qui attendait plus de six mois entre un
mois pour moi personnellement qui se
voulait mon sens déjà acheté des maisons
et puis c'est trop cher
ce sont de gros loyer
parce que les messages location
le jugement parce qu'un financement de
la maison
vous avez tous qui incombe
faut payer le terrain combien le mètre
carré
il faut le payer ça coûte très cher
ne tient pas qu'aux plus le trac à faut
payer des tréteaux de ce que j'en sais
pas de maison
là il ya du jamais vu une entreprise
noir
se sont pas des entreprises de
bienfaisance en ce sont des gens qui
sont là pour gagner de l'argent
alors moi j'estime que le la
construction est trop cher de
brillamment
elle est trop cher il ya certainement de
gros bénéfices
il y des cultes en fin de mois en dépit
ce qu'elle vous la santé à partir de
quelle date à peu près on va
vers le bas vers le vin alors comment ça
se passe quand ça se traduit on voit là
on commence à sortir dit au début du
mans sur les gros ballon
au milieu du mois on sort de billets de
10 francs et à la fin du mois on sort la
pièce de cinq fois la pièce daf il n'ya
pas trompé
j'ai invité yann le gal 30
[Musique]
tiendront à votre avis la peur la fin du
mois ça touche catégorie très importante
de français pour touchent probablement
la majorité des français c'est
d'ailleurs une des raisons qui nous ont
amenés au moment où on devait discuter
le gouvernement des questions du salaire
minimum des allocations familiales du
montant des retraites etc a essayé de
faire ce qu'on appelait budget team
c'est à dire à essayer de savoir comment
les gens faisait pour y arriver quand
vous fait alors on a essayé de changer
la méthode c'est qu'il ya des méthodes
qui existent officiel qui consiste à
calculer des anis moyens nous nous
sommes partis d'une autre réalité nous
avons essayé de mieux connaître la
réalité vécue par les travailleurs et
par leur famille alors on s'est aperçu
qu'il y avait deux ordres de dépenses
dans les budgets des familles dans les
enveloppes y aurait du budget des
familles il y avait d'abord les dépenses
totalement incompressibles qui sont
celles du loyer du gaz de l'électricité
de l'eau les impôts des traites etc et
vous savez les travailleurs ils tiennent
à payer ce qui dépasse et dont ils
tiennent à payer ses dépenses en premier
puis avec les autres celles qui restent
en quelque sorte c'est à dire
l'alimentation c'est à dire
l'habillement les transports les loisirs
enfin le reste et on a constaté qu'on
pouvait parfaitement
regardez comment les choses se passaient
en prenant comme on dit des indicateurs
des normes qui sont celles fixées par
l'état lui-même finalement que tout le
monde connaît par exemple pour
l'habitation prenant les tarifs des hlm
une chambre à paris au studio hlm ses
350 francs par mois bon en prenant pour
la nourriture la norme qui est admise
pour les tickets restaurant donc savait
que s'est fixé par décret actuellement
de 10 francs par repas on a regardé les
tarifs officiels des transports on a
regardé les choses comme ça de manière
objective sans passion et sans chercher
à priori à trouver un chiffre nous avons
nous aussi essayé en calculant ce budget
type pour une famille de deux enfants
premier poste le logement nous savons
que pour une famille de deux enfants
dans la région parisienne c'est un f4
loyers et charges 710 francs
la consommation moyenne pour
l'électricité et le gaz est pour
l'électricité de 36 francs pour le gaz
de 16 francs pour les transports les
parents utilisent la carte orange tandis
que les enfants qui vont à l'école tout
près sorte une fois par semaine aller
retour ce qui fait un total de 20
tickets soit pour l'ensemble 98 francs
nous avons ajouté les traite une
télévision une machine à laver 200
francs par mois
pour la nourriture nous nous sommes
fondés sur le chaque restaurant chaque
tickets coûtant 10 francs dont cinq sont
payées par l'employeur ce qui fait un
total de 1981 francs pour le budget
alimentation
pour l'habillement nous avons utilisé un
catalogue aux prix modérés nous avons
compté pour l'homme un pull-over un
costume un imperméable une paire de
chaussures pour la femme une paire de
chaussures une jupe et d'un chemisier
un pull-over
un an tout pour les enfants 2 anorak
depuis le revers
de pantalon deux paires de chaussures
nous avons fait la moyenne par mois
ce qui donne un budget habillement
272 francs 90
entretien
vaisselle et lessive
30 francs par mois puis le budget
vacances vvf pour trois semaines
une moyenne de 220 francs
les enfants vont en colonie de vacances
ce qui représente 45 jours avant
françois 150 francs
pour les vacances la famille prend le
train en billets congé soit 800 km à 64
francs en moyenne
un quotidien par jour 36 francs de café
par jour 60 francs
un paquet de cigarettes
55 francs
total de ce budget minimum
3827 190 sans compter
combien gens en france ne s'en sortent
pas et quand on pense que d'après les
chiffres que nous avons il ya à l'heure
actuelle plus de 8 millions de
travailleurs qui gagnent moins de 2000
francs par mois ce qui est clair c'est
que la majorité des français
actuellement n'y arrive pas vous
l'ignorez pas malgré tout que il ya
peut-être deux correctifs à apporter le
premier c'est le travail au noir qui se
développe beaucoup elle second c'est le
deuxième salaire qui nettoie ses
fréquents il faut d'abord dire qu'il y a
cette situation n'est pas encore
parfaitement anormal il ya le fait que
les salaires sont insuffisants et les
prestations sociales aussi qui a une
augmentation de l'endettement qui a un
développement des inégalités et puis il
est vrai aussi que ça apporte la
démonstration que le fait de travailler
à deux dans un ménage deviennent de plus
en plus effectivement de nécessité et
qu'enfin il faut bien arriver à manger à
la fin du mois donc tous les moyens sont
recherchés par les travaillaient tous
ceux qui ont des difficultés pour s'en
sortir c'est vrai
[Musique]
la défense symbole de la puissance ou de
la mythologie de l'expansion depuis dix
ans l'ouest de paris a littéralement
explosé avec la naissance de ce nouveau
quartier
la réalité c'est la construction d'un
énorme quartier d'affaires avec derrière
sur plutôt sur courbevoie la création de
logements hlm construit vite il y a cinq
ans au beau temps de la croissance
l'autre gym vous voyez qualifié sa femme
monique habitent avec leurs deux enfants
à courbevoie un appartement f3
claude gilles travaille dans une petite
entreprise de tôlerie descend quartier
[Musique]
ses juges on peut parler un petit peu
vous coupez la machine
[Applaudissements]
il ya peu près dix ans vous travaillez
dans cette demandeuse en 12 ans 12 ans
est actuellement vous avez de gros
problèmes de fin de mois oui en ce
moment oui depuis les réductions
d'horaires de mai donc la paye a diminué
environ
90 milles francs par mois vous gagnez
combien et vous gagnez actuellement
combien disons que j'arrive à faire des
mois
trois cent trente mille francs il est
maintenant j'arrive à peu près de temps
le 30 mai
ça représente une perte très sensible
pour vous puisque sensible même très
fort
comme l'expliqué vous faites
baisse de travail
la conjoncture n'étant pas tellement
bonne bien sûr automatiquement
l'entreprise s'est trouvé avec beaucoup
moins de travail
on a été obligé de réduire les horaires
schématiquement les heures
supplémentaires tomberont l'apave dette
diminuer d'autant
avant vous n'aviez pas de problème avant
non au niveau qu'on lui connaît il
répond on roulait pas sur l'or mais en
train de vivre est gentil vous regardez
par exemple cette photo là qu'est ce que
ça vous suggérez
l'époque de mariage mais le bon alors
quelles sont les différentes périodes
c'est l'histoire quelles sont les dates
importantes les périodes et par rapport
aux fins de mois comme on peut dire
depuis soixante deux aéronautes mariage
jusqu'à
du progrès sur normal
on avait la foi l on devait se marier
poupées ty et là c'est un petit peu la
zone enfin je symbolise assez bien
besoin très bien marcher tout seul puis
ça nous met les années et les dix
premières années les bowls la fin du
procès les premières vacances c'est
pendant cette période là et pour laraque
ensuite ces points cette période par le
plat
à partir de 68 comment est-ce que ça a
évolué alors à partir de 68 donc nous
attendons notre deuxième enfant et on
décide d'acheter la nôtre première
caravane pour faire du caravaning pour
que les vacances ne coûte un peu moins
cher en location voilà des photos la 2
qui datent du jeu pendant la première
caravane méchoui à la falaise juillet 69
là ça c'est une image de l'expansion
d'un tiers à l'aise et puis il y avait
le cou et puis avec et ce sans doute
plutôt arranger les choses 68 oui amener
du beurre dans les épinards
alors la pointe de la fin de mois parce
que
cette époque là ces deux ans après 68
salle est encore long
et puis d'un seul coup après 74 les
la conjoncture la boîte est tellement
bonne et bien sûr dans cette course a
été la dégringolade
dégringolade de 90 mille francs par mois
pour vous pour moi ça représente une
somme considérable considérable surtout
dans un budget
[Musique]
il n'y a pas que le chômage total le
chômage partiel a touché en france en
375000 chef de famille et le nombre des
salariés français qui gagne aujourd'hui
entre 2000 et 2500 francs par mois et de
10 9%
[Musique]
vous pouvez me donner claude geslin
exemples précis de difficultés
budgétaires de fin de mois en fin de
mois enfin début du mois puisque le 10
du mois revient sur la paye est terminée
il n'y en a plus on peut reprendre les
grands postes et si vous voulez
rejoindre pour décembre pour décembre
nous avons la traite caravane 42 1790
anciens francs
l'assurance de la maison 30 mille francs
les impôts locaux 32000 une vidange de
la voiture 7000 francs
le loyer 62000
vous avez les supermarchés 26000
9000 l'essence de la voiture 5000 deux
fois et encore supermarchés c1000 fois
ce sont des chiffres précis vous arrivez
vous pouvez calculer la salle où vous
arrivez les chiffres précis la paye le
10 du mois et à la paille est combien la
paix était de 2 287 1912 france voici
donc si le 10 du mois vous n'avez pas
le peu d'argent que green munich pour
relayer notre oeil
était impossible ce mois-ci ce mois ci
soit impossible on a eu donc la somme
d'allocations familiales pour des
enfants 22 mille francs
donc mes semaines en tant que
nourrissent et puis alors j'avais
quelques remboursements de sécurité
sociale en retard sinon on n'aura pas pu
y arriver j'estime que pour ce mois ci
je me suis pas trop mal défendu venez
que c'est une une vraie période dorée
structure ah oui une grande période
j'espère que ça durera pas trop
longtemps tess caractérise commandes
restriction bah écoutez depuis quelques
temps on achète plus de journaux aucune
dépense du côté journaux j'ai quelques
livres de mode bien sûr mais ce sont des
livres qu'on me donne je n'en gens
n'achètent plus haut point de vue
habillement aucune fausse dépenses j'ai
d'ailleurs des amis très gentil qui me
donne des affaires pour mes enfants que
je modifie moi même je fais beaucoup de
choses par moi-même et puis au point de
vue mettons le pressing aussi je donne
rarement des affaires au pressing je
fais tout à part un gros manteau ou des
pantalons bon alors là je le donne mais
j'ai pas vraiment de dépenses de ce côté
là j'arrive à faire beaucoup de choses
moi-même puis les invitations ben
maintenant les invitations ou non fait
plus ou alors chacun part et d'autre
part
on essaye de se réunir en ayant une
quote-part de façon à ce que le petit
chêne
ce report a touché terre vous ne
dépensez plus que le strict minimum
budget alimentaire en ce moment on s'en
tient au budget alimentaire
[Musique]
pour faire leurs courses
comme beaucoup de ménages français
depuis deux ans monique et claude jules
ont appris à connaître par coeur la
photographie exacte de la hausse des
prix dans le supermarché où ils vont au
lieu de flâner comme avant ils vont
systématiquement et directement aux
produits les moins chers
[Musique]
et qui a le plus augmenté alors asie
c'est le vin la viande et légumes mais
aussi les vêtements l'essence le fioul
et donc les charges locatives
[Musique]
non
n'est pas venu avec vos enfants non
toi non parce que actuellement comme je
ne veux pas leur refuser certaines
choses je préfère éviter de les emmener
pour ne pas dans leur refuser
quand j'ai des achats à faire pour eux
alors là je n'emmène spécialement
[Musique]
on n'a plus le pouvoir d'achat que l'on
avait avant de pouvoir d'achat
maintenant est ce pour cette année pour
cette fin d'année du bo depuis
la rentrée des vacances et 2,0
pouvoir d'achat réduit à néant si on
fume ans et si je fais le calcul de mes
années antérieures
on avait un pouvoir d'achat beaucoup
plus important là tout a été réglé année
mazen est ce que vous sentez des
problèmes de fin de mois pour les gens
au niveau de la caisse
c'est à dire cherche est bouclée à la
fin du mois
je bénis 2,3 en moyenne
[Musique]
et
les sommes dépensées général au début du
mois entre 200 et 300 à la fin du mot
c'est qui est ce qu'il ya des gens qui
font des réflexions sur les prix oui là
vraiment c'est tous ces rallyes c'est
arrivé avec lui
j'ai encore boudées
en général
[Musique]